i am i have been profoundly moved by the
latest case of a white police officer
killing a black man ended as
controversially as it began
officer potter made a mistake
that ended tragically
kim potter charged with an accidental
killing faced a tearful judge who handed
down a sentence well below the state
guidelines of six to eight years it is
the sentence and judgment of this court
that you shall be committed to the
custody of the commissioner of
corrections
for a period of 24 months
daunting's life was cut short the family
of the 20 year old man potter shot dante
wright wanted no leniency
you took his future
what he could have done and there was so
many things
april 11th was the worst day of my life
a police officer who was supposed to
serve and protect so much took so much
away from us
she took our baby boy with a single
gunshot through his heart she shattered
mine
my life and my world will never ever be
the same
a tearful potter addressed the family
directly i didn't even have a right to
be in the same room with you
i am so sorry
that i hurt you so badly
my heart
is broken wright's family says tears are
not enough i feel cheated i feel hurt
i'm very upset
they were so tied up into her feelings
and were hurt what's going on with her
that they forgot about my son being
killed
you know people in our community have
got sentences the greater time
for selling marijuana
the sentence followed an april 2021
traffic stop that ended dante wright's
life
police camera video shows wright
apparently trying to escape a traffic
stop potter then a suburban minneapolis
police officer fires what she says she
thought was a taser
[Music]
the weapon she drew was her gun kim
potter has agreed to travel the state of
minnesota talking to police departments
about the dangers of weapons confusion
so other officers don't experience the
tragedy that she did
though disappointed wright's family says
they're grateful for at least one rarity
a white police officer was convicted of
killing an unarmed black man john
hendren al jazeera minneapolis